[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanto è brutto aveva un'opinione e non
poterla esprimere quanto è brutto fai di
tutto per piacere agli altri ma non
sentirsi mai abbastanza
ma i giusti mai adatti quanto è brutto
durante l'interrogazione di inglese
accorgersi che i compagni in fondo alla
classe ci sta filmando e
l'interrogazione si fa via via più
difficile
e tu entrò in ansia e affinità
l'interrogazione non pensi ai 5 che ha
appena ricevuto
ma a quel filmato a quel video che il
tuo compagno con due clic in maniera
leggera quasi completo sapevo le ha
condiviso con il mondo e per l'ennesima
volta che ti senti preso in giro
vorresti fuggire e come te milioni gli
altri ragazzini
provate ad immaginare quanto sia butto
scartarsi 124 10 selphy cercando la
posizione migliore per apparire è più
carini possibile una volta pubblicato
stare lì minuti e minuti in attesa di
vedere quanta quante persone ma
soprattutto a quali persone piace nella
nostra foto per avere la conferma che
siamo veramente carini quanto pensiamo
e così se entrano il profilo dell'amica
o del influencer e si accorge che in
effetti non abbiamo ricevuto abbastanza
consensi e un po alla volta ci si inizia
a sentire meno carini meno giusti meno
adatti
e così si pensa dovrei forse utilizzare
un altro filtro o dovrei provare a
mettere in posa come ha fatto la
compagna di classe a bordo piscina in
costume e si pensa tutto a tutto per una
riprova sociale in una rete in cui
dovremo sentirci più liberi e invece
sentiamo più sicuri e più soli avete
presente quando siete in un locale
affollatissimo o in una metropolitana
con migliaia di persone
e voi avete bisogno di comunicare con un
amico ma chiaramente non riesce a
sentirvi né tantomeno capirvi non è che
non vuole ascoltarvi è che proprio non
ce la fa c'è troppo rumore troppa
confusione
ecco questo è il mondo in cui molti
adolescenti vivono un mondo in cui sono
così vicini ma allo stesso tempo così
lontani
un mondo in cui non è che hanno una
mancanza di socialità come molti pensano
è che proprio non ce la fanno
si urlano in faccia ma non riescono a
capirsi una solitudine nella folla e
questo è proprio ciò che succede a molti
adolescenti nei social network pensate
che in media un ragazzino italiano dai
12 ai 16 anni passa due ore e mezza al
giorno sullo smartphone e questo studio
ci dimostra come le persone che passano
più di due ore al giorno sullo
smartphone tendono a sentirsi più sole
ma come siamo sempre più social e sempre
più a sociali ma com'è possibile
è un corto circuito un paradosso ma
scienza si sa è la base più facile della
vita di una persona
la fase in cui si rompe quella perfetta
bolla di protezione che rata dai nostri
genitori e ci si scontra con la realtà
con la realtà la fuori tremendamente
veloce tremendamente in continuo
cambiamento e soprattutto senza
sicurezze e forse anche per questo che i
ragazzi cominciano a cercare un nuovo
rifugio e così trovano i social un mondo
facile un mondo bello pieno di like
pieno di amici però gli immagini
patinate che ti rassicurano aprono un
profilo instagram che è un profilo
chiuso stringono assieme tutti gli amici
con i quali interagiscono continuamente
perché dovete sapere che vostri figli
hanno una forte voglia di raccontarsi ma
sostituiscono pian piano le interazioni
offline con quelle online proprio perché
sono più numerose più facili più veloci
e pian piano non si accorgono non si
accorgono che si stanno chiudendo in una
bolla una bolla di solitudine una bolla
di solitudine sociale al quale ai pochi
di noi ci pensano e questo lo fanno
anche per sfuggire dagli adulti gli
adulti che spesso li giudicano non li
capiscono non comprendono il loro mondo
perché sapete per loro
molti di voi molti di voi adulti vi
ritengono degli immigrati digitali o
persino dei deportati digitali
ma pensate che gli adulti proprio perché
adulti sappiano muoversi nel web
agilmente senza problemi beh io ricordo
che prima del boom dei social media si
ripetevano e mi ripetevano continuamente
fasi come ma cosa usi facebook a fare io
ho i miei amici li vedo di persona
oppure ma butta via quel cellulare basta
perdere tempo
non serve a niente vivi la vita reale
e quindi concepivano il mondo web come
qualcosa di estremamente negativo pieno
di pericoli di insidie di persone pronte
a fregarti e ora è tutto cambiato
ora gli stessi adulti sono spesso
proprio loro i primi a pubblicare di
tutto e di più
persino le foto dei figli che prima non
volevano in rete
e così gli adulti si sono costruiti una
bolla una bolla che li fa sentire più
sicuro invincibili che vogliono
utilizzare per urlare il loro i del
mondo ma che non si accorgono che
nonostante mi piace mi piace dopo mi
piace like dopo like aumentano loro
consenso sui social in realtà sono
sempre le stesse persone che li seguono
perché per effetto dell'algoritmo che
regola i maggiori social media noi
vediamo soltanto le persone che ci
piacciono e che hanno idee simili è
l'algoritmo stesso ci priva della
possibilità molto spesso di connetterci
con persone diverse
perché queste sarebbero in noi ad agire
in modo negativo e quindi questo
fenomeno psicologico si chiama backfire
effect proprio perché l'indole umana e
quella di cercare affermazioni idee che
confermino le nostre credenze quando
invece ci scontriamo con qualcosa di
diverso semplicemente non gli diamo peso
o ancora peggio lo sentiamo come un
attacco personale e quindi lo prendiamo
di pancia ed agiamo in modo aggressivo
radicando ulteriormente le nostre idee e
questo se notate lo vediamo online con
gli adulti molto spesso che ad esempio
su facebook
qualsiasi cosa che trovino in linea con
il loro pensiero
l'aj condividono immediatamente senza
nemmeno verificarne le fonti
se invece c'è qualcosa di diverso un
commento una persona con un'idea
divergente beh lì si scatenano si
scatenano i commenti aggrediscono
insultano senza nemmeno pensare che in
effetti dietro l'altro allo schermo c'è
un'altra persona e senza nemmeno pensare
che in effetti possono fare un danno ma
soprattutto non si rendono conto che
così rendono i social un ambiente
invivibile un vero far west si accorgono
molto probabilmente che in effetti
facebook ha soltanto sostituito il
vecchio bar solo che al bar
ovviamente noi ci parlavamo di persona
lì su facebook invece parliamo contro un
muro
un muro che è una bacheca ma una bacheca
che in cui i pensieri una volta scritti
non vanno più via
ricordo a 14 anni che a scuola mia ci
parlavano del web come qualcosa di
estremamente negativo qualcosa da cui
stare distante tentando di spaventarci
ma allo stesso tempo nonostante questi
interventi salivano a vista d'occhio il
numero di miei coetanei che
semplicemente subivano il web subivano
fenomeni virtuali negativi come il cyber
bullismo o la dipendenza da smartphone e
loro mi sono chiesto ma il web è così
veramente allora per pura curiosità ho
iniziato a scoprirne le potenzialità ad
esempio ricordo di aver creato la prima
pagina facebook per la pizzeria vicino a
casa mia in cambio di qualche pizza che
poi rivendeva mia mamma ma lì è stato
solo l'inizio è stato l'inizio del fatto
che ho iniziato a capire che in effetti
nel web in internet sono grandissime
potenzialità e ho conosciuto persone che
vogliono cambiare il mondo e gay e che
grazie ai social si sono messi in luce e
così ha detto perché non ci provo
anch'io
e nato così social warning il movimento
etico digitale formato da oltre 200
formatori volontari appassionati di web
che sensibilizzano ragazzi e genitori in
tutta italia
sulle potenzialità rischi di internet
gratuitamente social warning perché deve
esserci un focus sociale
un focus sociale in una transizione che
ci riguarda tutti
da ragazzino all'adulto perché il
digitale rimescola le carte e
dell'educazione da un'era in cui è
soltanto l'adulto ad insegnare al
ragazzo ad una in cui il genitore può
imparare dal figlio ad esempio a
riconoscere una famous ho una notizia
falsa
proprio grazie all'esperienza che ha
accumulato online ci accorgiamo allora
che abbiamo bisogno di una nuova
educazione digitale di una nuova
educazione che faccia da collante tra
generi e generazioni perché c'è bisogno
dell'intervento anche dei ragazzi che
aiutino i genitori ma soprattutto dei
genitori perché i genitori devono
continuare a fare i genitori anche nel
web i dove la loro figura è fondamentale
fondamentale per far riflettere i propri
figli in quello che trovano online e sul
bilanciamento con la vita reale non
dobbiamo dimenticarci infatti che la
generazione z quella dal 95 in poi non
ha vissuto la transizione tra il mondo
analogico a quello digitale e quindi se
non vogliamo continuare a dimenticare
gli usi e le tradizioni dei nostri nonni
dobbiamo impegnarci tutti assieme a
costruire un ponte un ponte tra
generazione un ponte digitale ma
soprattutto reale e questa è una
grandissima sfida per noi tutti in sala
perché il tablet può essere un
fantastico strumento per educare vostro
figlio e non può essere un semplice baby
sitter perché i social possono essere
una finestra sulla conoscenza e sul
mondo e non può essere un semplice
sfogatoio e perché il web il web deve
aiutarci a coltivare le connessioni
importanti e non può essere un buco nero
di paura ma solo così solo così
riusciremo assieme
a creare una transizione dal subire il
web come utenti passivi a goderne tutti
assieme delle immense potenzialità di
guadagno economico e di conoscenze
personali
vi lascio con un augurio che portiamo
tutti i giorni in giro per l'italia con
il movimento etico digitale e che da
oggi spero sia anche per voi un grande
messaggio di transizione prendi il
meglio dal passato
vivi il presente pensa al futuro grazie